he stands out in a crowd vitali
klitschko the ukrainian opposition
leader and former boxing champion who's
trying to steer his country closer to
europe these images are from december
after ukrainian President Viktor
Yanukovych rejected a proposed trade
agreement with the EU a short time later
Klitschko retired from boxing to focus
fully on politics Klitschko's party was
increasingly thrust into the spotlight
gaining international supporters
including the German Foreign Minister at
the time Guiteau vest avella album 30 we
want to encourage European values the
doorway to Europe remains open to your
crane una and often long do job remix is
happy that what is happening the protest
an independent square are resonating not
just in Ukraine but also in Germany need
you here niceville crania supposing you
mention you the holder of a PhD
Klitschko is sometimes nicknamed dr.
Ironfist and the acronym of the party he
leads who da means punch now he's a
member of the ukrainian parliament and
one of the opposition's most prominent
figures as a fighter he used to say it's
okay to lose a round or two as long as
you win the fight the fight he's now
engaged in is certainly the toughest of
his career